people ask me all the time they're like
do you want your kids to be
entrepreneurs I'm like only if they want
to be I'm petrified they would ever
consider it because I was one I want
them to like their thing the way I love
my thing
even if it was like I wouldn't want to
be a Patriots fan but like it's just so
obvious to me that like forcing someone
to be what you want them to be is like
the worst for an employee or a friend
for a child that's bad to do it for your
siblings or your buddy forcing round
holes into square pegs especially out of
your own insecurities is the big flaw of
modern parenting and historical
parenting do you know any doctors
lawyers and Engineers actively are that
right now actively right this second
tens of thousands of people over the
next five years will listen to this
exact podcast and this exact moment
they're 39 years old making a ton of
money it all looks good and they are
pissed all the way through because they
never tried to be an Olympian or they
didn't get to become a chef or they
never tried to be an Archer